is looking for his wife he showed
reporters her photograph hoping someone
has seen her
Ezra abood from Syria was on the ship
that capsized off the Greek Coast she
was traveling with her brother no women
or children are thought to have survived
but searches carried on into Thursday
hundreds of people were packed onto the
boat as this Coast Guard photo shows
both on the deck and below deck Kassem
spoke to us through an interpreter
we want
that uh his wife come to Germany to him
and it was their difficult
that
she come about a legal way
then he tried to break her
across Libya and then to Italy and then
it's happened but we all know
Ezra abood paid five thousand dollars
for her passage like many of the
survivors in this Warehouse in Kalamata
all of them men Aid workers give them
food water and medicine but no one can
answer the question that really matters
to them are their loved ones still alive
I visited the survivors it's
heart-wrenching I don't know if you can
consider these men lucky when there are
700 people at the bottom of the sea they
told us the women and children were in
the ship's hold some said they were in
the refrigerators it seems they couldn't
save themselves
Europe is grappling with the Dilemma of
how to offer safe passage to all those
who need International protection while
at the same time controlling its borders
but developments are outstripping policy
making as numbers of Economic migrants
and Asylum Seekers accumulate even a new
migration pact under discussion doesn't
guarantee Safe Harbor to all those who
want or need it meanwhile people
traffickers are meeting the demand Greek
authorities have detained nine young men
over this incident they were among the
survivors but it's thought they were
part of the crew it's possible their
junior functionaries not the ultimate
beneficiaries of the three million
dollars this passage may have been worth
This Man Came From Italy looking for a
relative like Kasem he's been told to
wait for three or four days
for now relatives aren't even allowed to
talk to the survivors to find out
information they don't know what to do
meanwhile phone calls are flooding into
the harbor Masters office from relatives
who want answers John saropoulos Al
Jazeera galamata